how do you I get how do you justify a
rejection of identitarian ISM when a
pillar of the neo-marxist strategy is to
demographically replace the indigenous
people of Europe London it's less than
half ethnically English okay so let's
take that question apart first of all it
isn't self-evident to me that it is
specifically a neo-marxist strategy to
demographically replace the indigenous
peoples of Europe and I don't think
that's the strategy anyways even if
that's the outcome because you have to
distinguish between strategy and outcome
the strategy and principle is to bring
in immigrants to balance out declining
birthrate now I'm not saying I agree
with that I'm just saying that that's
what the strategy is and then the next
part of the question is predicated on
the assumption that identitarian ISM is
necessarily the answer to the problem of
the problem that's being identified
which is characterized as excess
immigration first of all we'd have to
figure out exactly what identitarian is
a means because it isn't clear if it
means radical right-wing ethnic
nationalism I don't think that that's
going to be particularly constructive if
it means having a sensible discussion
about what the appropriate limits might
be on immigration and to think about
that over the long run and also to have
a serious discussion about the degree to
which say Islam and and the West the
values of Islam and the West are
actually commensurate then that has to
be obviously has to be done but so I'm
afraid that to answer that question I'd
have to know more about exactly how
these terms were being were being
defined especially with regards to
identitarian ism because it's a vague
word and